[Music]
this is not real
this is not real this is not real this
isn't happening
kate uh tell me this isn't really
happening
i hear there's uh something you don't
like the looks of we discovered a very
large comet oh good for you it's headed
directly towards earth
this comet is what we call a planet
killer
at this exact moment i say we sit tight
and assess
sit tight and assess sit tight and then
assess
the sit tight part comes first then you
got to digest it that's the assessment
period
this is the worst news in the history of
humanity he just blew us off what are we
gonna do we have to release the
information so we just leak it
our guests today have made a pretty big
discovery in space
how big is this thing going i can't
destroy my ex-wife's house is that
possible
there's a 100 percent chance that we're
all going to die
okay
okay
well the hands of astronomers can come
back anytime but the yelling lady melts
not so much
we're gonna get the news out there one
way or another it's real and it's coming
jesus christ you could have just called
me
this comment contains 30 trillion
dollars worth of material what are
trillions of dollars matter if we're all
going to die
this would be terrible
[Music]
you guys discovered a comment i have a
tattoo of a shooting star on my back
oh that's that's terrific
this could be a complete disaster this
is already a disaster
you know that girl from live tv said
we're all going to die no girl
[Applause]
you'll never take me alive
there it is
a giant comet hurtling its way
[Music]
i did have the fbi put that bag over
your head
they don't do that the cia does but i
made them do it you know i had a feeling
it's a good feeling because that is what
i did and it was very funny and cool
[Music]
[Music]
you